hey guys solar in London today and I
tweeted out and asked you guys what I
should do while I'm here and I'm also
doing a little mini scavenger hunt not
only for me reading your tweets but also
for you because I've got some emoji
stickers you guys find them take a
selfie or do something I don't know
leave it there though for the next
rehearse this is art and I've tested but
you can't remove them very very easily
because I didn't want to like yeah it'll
be alright let's let's place the first
one shall we hey hey hey hey our next
stop is the London Eye and we're just
taking you guys to correct us lioka the
River Thames is for mountains pronounced
Tim's its TEM is e I don't know what
represents a river having a wave
with some big man and the London Eye
maybe I'll just steal some footage from
the previous time that I wrote this
because this line is really long
something
you see in one of the row
usually when I travel I always bring
quest bars and I forgot them so we're
gonna go to GNC to see if they have them
and I'm hoping what because I'm going to
do a quick horse freaking Bob I'm so
excited
we're gonna survive survive
and the guard
somebody suggested that we go to Shake
Shack in Covent Garden there's the Shake
Shack here
I've had it before so the apples are the
science backwards it is
I danced right over there I have okay
we're here but I need absolutely nothing
from the APUs Taurus I just kind of
learned to walk in and be like hey guess
what we're here we're here we can leave
now unless you want to look around
somebody had change of heart I play
everything I could possibly need I want
to see the architecture it's really cool
it for sure
it's so pretty and the awesome glass
staircase you fancy huh a little
adventure today to a close we'll see you
guys tomorrow for some more fun stuff
and probably tomorrow I think is our
first Call of Duty day so we're gonna be
heading over to caught champs and
getting the tournament started so I'll
see you guys